[Music]
why
is it that we play the games that we
play
for some gaming is a way to experience
something they'd never be able to in
real life
an escapist fantasy that transports them
into a
whole new reality i present to you
tifa lockhart what do you think jenny
i look good for others it's an
opportunity to develop and enhance
skills that they already have
a kind of mental training dojo i can
also trade and take and take and if
takes i
take if takes takes takes queenie two
queen h4 g3 knight g3
check c6 queen b7 knight h1 king there
i don't know what's going on i'm just
going to castle i don't want to think
too much
and sometimes it's simply a way to
unwind
and relax after a hard day's work
come in we got the toilet on the side we
got a little little thing
oh i woke up like this we got two sinks
oh i wish our bathroom was to speak in
real life
but why the hell do people play
escape from tarkov no seriously it's
pretty much the dark souls of fps titles
frustrating
doesn't even begin to describe it
the ats the rail
guns going like this
no no no oh he's invincible
what is that oh this guy's just rushed
in here he just
knows me it's me
but in the unforgiving world of tarkov
there are
true gluttons for punishment and chief
among them
is pestly an aussie streaming sensation
who not only plays the game at an
insanely high level
there are a set of gods within this game
and pestly is without a doubt amongst
them but has made
mastering it his life's work this game
is so in depth
and even myself with the amount of hours
i've put in this game
i'm still learning stuff every day
i win get the [ __ ] out of here so what
exactly inspired pestly to exchange
his military career for the streaming
life
why was he drawn to tarkov in particular
and
how has he been able to turn a
notoriously stressful game
into one of twitch's most amusing
streams
just [ __ ] sit down enjoy the game
right
shut the [ __ ] up play the game and enjoy
it if you're not happy
come back in three months
[Music]
there are a few things that pastely is
not very good at like using the stairs
if anyone who doesn't know i fell down
the staircase when i was in europe
and uh hurt a full flight of stairs head
first
utilizing kitchen appliances as intended
pinnacle my streaming career i'm playing
with a microwave over my lap or
keeping those pesky important dates
straight
in his head christmas is on like 23rd of
december
24th 24th is the thursday then what's
the day after christmas
but what he is undeniably good at is
escape
from tarkov
oh billy
all right son good night son
i'm in the middle of fighting get into
my wine
fittingly before turning into every
other tarkov player's worst nightmare
pestly spent eight years in the
australian army
finding himself stationed for a large
chunk of that time
in southeast asia and while most people
would consider avoiding
active conflict zones as a blessing
at some point pesterly just felt that he
was spinning his wheels
imagine training for a job that you you
know you're really passionate about and
you're really driven
with but you never actually get to do
your job that's where it's unlucky but
at the same time i i probably you know
could have i might have dodged a bullet
because of it and so
in late 2017 pastely decided to leave
the army for good
not only did he need a break to rest his
weary bones
but he also had to figure out what his
next steps would be
i wasn't really sure what i wanted to do
so i actually decided i'd save some
money
and i'll take three months three months
where
i'm not going to work at all but
sitting on his hands for months on end
wasn't exactly pestly's idea of a good
time
and sure he had outdoor activities like
fishing to keep himself occupied
but he'd been passionate about gaming
since he was younger
absolutely addicted to world of warcraft
i actually lost a girlfriend over it
uh she called me up one day said it's
over you play world of warcraft too much
pretty much
post enlistment though and now 30 year
old pestilene didn't really have many
people left to play with
so in order to still enjoy the social
aspect of video games
he decided to pick up streaming i never
started content creation or streaming
to make money to be like well known or
any of that or for cloud or anything
i literally did it just to make some
friends and instead of playing something
chill and relatively carefree
pastely found himself drawn to something
that was the complete
opposite of that
now if there's one thing that can be
said about escape from tarkov it's that
the game takes the concept of
art imitating life to an absolute
extreme
it's an attention-demanding
hyper-realistic military shooter that
initially launched back in 2017
with the game's developer proudly
declaring that it was not
intended for filthy casuals
what the f ever at first streaming was
something pestly did for fun on the side
while working as a firefighter but by
the time 2018
rolled around he decided to turn it into
his full-time gig
how about i take two years of my life
and i'll go for two years i'm gonna go
as hard as i can
i'll start a youtube channel i'll do
everything right and i'll work my ass
off and we'll see where it goes
and while his youtube channel was
initially more of a grower than a shower
it was on twitch that pastely really
began to pick up momentum
and by the end of the year he found
himself being recognized as australia's
breakout creator it's been an absolutely
amazing year for me
and um holy crap but it wasn't until
tarkov received a
massive update that pestilence numbers
really shot up into the stratosphere
with in-game drops
enabled at the end of 2019 it seemed
like any pleb with a twitch handle was
running around
getting shot in tarkov
i thought he had a stun effect what
but all these new players had merely
adopted
tarkov pestly streaming career on the
other hand
was literally shaped and molded by the
game
so much so that despite playing on
crappy australian servers
he still manages to be deadly
i'm a [ __ ] god but just because
pesterly enjoys digital bloodbaths
doesn't mean he isn't a genuinely nice
guy
in real life the entire ten thousand
dollar prize that he won in the code red
escape from tarkov tournament for
instance
went towards pestly's ongoing efforts to
raise a million dollars
for starlight an australian charity for
sick children
if you donated a dollar if you donated
thousands of dollars it all really does
that out and it all does amazing things
for uh
for the kids and despite winning a fair
number of world-class tarkov tournaments
pastely is not above giving advice to
new players
whether it's through compiling his
extensive game knowledge into easily
digestible tier lists and tip guides
or just speaking straight from the heart
on stream the more in life that you
stop caring about other people the
happier you'll be
like stop caring about what other people
think of you and and beating other
people and being better than other
people
just do what you enjoy most of the time
pestilence community appreciates the
hard work and dedication that he puts
into his broadcasts because that was
laid off for three months just got back
into work you got me through rough times
man
thanks so much for the content can't
wait to watch your adventures thanks
dude but
of course like any other streamer
pestilence had to deal with his
fair share of criticism just a friendly
reminder that
still looks like a wombat
still at the end of the day pastely
knows that his viewers are the ones he
has to thank
for his continued online success i try
to reply to every single discord dm
there is i get a lot these days but like
i still try to reply to them all like
just try and be the best person you can
be and one of the things i'm big with my
community is paying it forward
like i'll do something for you and then
you do it for someone something for
someone else it doesn't have to be
directly back to me
and with that premise we can just make a
better society and a better community
now while it might seem as if pastely
has already found everything he was
looking for and can
proudly rest on his laurels that's not
actually the plan
his idea of traveling around europe with
his wife and
sharing their exploits with his fans did
not come to pass last year but pestly is
looking forward to his next adventure
but in the meantime you know exactly
where we'll find him
are you serious i lay down the same
[ __ ] bushes in are you
serious
you [ __ ] see that it's like you
across the sky
did you guys see that like a shooting
star is that new
has it always been shooting stars
just just fire three bullets if you're
listening
go bang bang bang
and while escape from tarkov is what
helped pastely find and expand his
support of community
as someone who has already changed
course once in his life
he isn't afraid to take chances and
shake things up some more
the next opportunity he gets after all
as pestly has already learned
sometimes success lies on the other side
of fear we all have our own mountains to
climb
all it takes is just one step
pastilli or pastely pastilli
pastely pastilli
[Music]
i have not played this game from dark
off i've heard that it's like
mercilessly unforgiving it's like
ridiculously difficult you just gotta
beat your head against it until you can
finally like
best it and beat it